what the heck happened here you know it
isn't even a hack that's how bad it is
it's like it that's how pathetic is that
is how pathetic it is I think what it
shows is that that that the kind of
information that we used to think was
private even answers the security
questions has been come up become a
commodity on the cyber underground so
basically from all these hacks this
stuff is collected it's put in giant
databases you can just go on on places
you know deep deep web web sites and
just buy it and that's apparently what
they did the IRS had a database that if
you gave them the enough information and
pretty simple information some last for
your social some security question
answers they would spit out your tax
returns that's what these guys did they
use the tax returns to file new returns
for the coming year and got the refund
to make them look authentic right so if
we take this web and back into it of how
they got there are we going to get to
the point that the IRS simply doesn't
have the budget or the manpower to
protect itself yeah I mean you get the
IRS is now in the crosshairs you have
people in Congress to congressmen who
are criticizing them because they've
been worn for months and years that this
is large but not just any resources and
the other side of that is yeah but we
haven't had enough money to fix these
systems so it's a giant pot of money
clearly one of the biggest numbers that
came out of this is that in 2013 the IRS
gave over 5 billion dollars in fake
refunds and and that's crazy man and
this is a drop that this is a drop in
the bucket and eighty percent of that
was organized crime so they're clearly
being hit by very serious organised
crime it's where the money is and the
IRS has to get it systems up to a point
where they can defend against these and
they basically are saying we don't have
the budget so the reason that the IRS
director Causton and holds an event like
this to discuss such cases is to draw
attention to the fact that the IRS is
under resourced and needs more money
from Congress absolutely yeah I mean
these systems are there not that
difficult to to implement but you need
the money to do it and they're basically
saying we don't have the money to do it
when you say they're not that difficult
to implement how not difficult so
something like this you know all they
would have had to do was institute some
sort of you know it may be a two-factor
thing where you had to send a send
another code to your phone or even have
these guys create a password at some
point they didn't have any of those very
very basic you know G
male is more secure than this stuff
Eric's looking for a summer job for his
daughters he's going what how is he he's
just getting through this step-by-step
50 million bucks just like that yeah and
then eight and they seem to be pretty
proud of the fact that they stopped
about half of these attacks but only
about half of them and they still gave
away 50 million dollars before they
figured it out